uh welcome uh tina katukata
to the february meeting of the community
strategy committee
um
we've obviously got some of our
participants welcome to the people that
are here in chambers we've also under
our red light settings we've also got
some members that are coming in through
zoom who are working from home
and obviously some members of the youth
council who i believe are online as well
so we've got a fairly
mixed agenda this afternoon
some very interesting reports
firstly we'll just go through the
apologies i've got apologies from
councillor phillips and councillor
bolger
just confirming whether councillor grant
may be online or councillor davis
maybe on the zoo
i'm not sure how we'd i think we'd see
them if they were
yeah
okay so we'll
log them as an apology anyway
at the stage
so that um
leaves us into our agenda uh for today
and our first item
um
is the progress report from the gore
youth council as i said early welcome to
hopefully uh
youth council members that um that are
leaving um sarah jake and
we've got we've got uh jessica and
georgia uh georgie
so uh
there's mark i'm trying to work out
where i look to see anyone i can look
over this way and see you mark how are
you mark
um i'll leave you to lead us through
this
thank you mr chair afterwards
it's been a very challenging year for
everyone including the youth council
having to constantly adapt to public
restrictions
however they've still managed to
organize a number of events often in
collaboration with other organizations
or groups
and they then reflected on these events
and discussed how to prove improve or
change the for the future
and those of you we've seen a real
increased confidence in the members and
a group of young people really need to
take things to that next level which is
really exciting
and so moving into the new year and
again we have to adapt to the current
climate
however we are really excited to
announce that this year we'll have a
youth council with 21
members that is more representative of
the community itself
including more community members
a voice for maori a voice for people
with disabilities and a voice for
newcomers as well
to reflect everyday organizational
structures the youth council has set up
a project management group
a communications group and an events
management group
and this will give each member of the
youth council an increased sense of
responsibility
and
envisaged also increases their ability
to operate supporting the community
to support this guest speakers have been
invited to share their knowledge and
skills online to enable youth counselors
to grow in those roles
um i'd like to say a huge thank you to
councillor nick grant i'm hopeful he's
online at the moment
for his support and guidance of the last
year the
members of the council really enjoy this
um
and i'd like to ask them to thank the
four people who have left the council at
the end of 2021
thank you mark and
yeah it is real pleasure to be able to
thank
those that are moving on from youth
council this year
i know that the contribution that
they've made is one that's been really
appreciated
but i'm just hoping that
through their time on youth council
they've
gained a whole lot of experience and
skills develop skills that they wouldn't
otherwise have had and i know that each
one of them
has got you know we've all got our
individual traits but each one of them
have bought
variety and um
an energy to to the youth council over
the last year or more
and i really wish them all the very best
for what
is ahead of them and and i know that a
number will be moving away moving out of
the district uh which in some ways is a
shame but actually you've got to move
away before you can come back and and i
know that they'll when they do go away
they'll gain a lot of skills and
experience but i'm hoping that they will
gain an appreciation of what this
community can do for or has done for
them and and what they can possibly do
to add to the the value
proposition that this community has so
wish them all the very best hope it goes
well
um but please remember us
uh as as time goes on and
to sarah and jake jessica and georgie
yeah all the very best from me and i
say that with sincerity on behalf of the
whole of the gore district council
we've enjoyed your time um and we
appreciate the energy you've brought
and and i hope that
the world works
the best it possibly will you work in
the world the best you possibly can um
from here on in so all the best
and and i guess just before
uh i finished talking about youth
council i just want to um add my
congratulations to mark who who picked
up the role of connecting this whole
group uh earlier on this year and done a
fantastic job and looking at those
you know those project groups that
you've you've set up with the
communications project management and
events that's really going to give the
youth council going forward something to
get the teeth into quite definitive
and i look forward to see what what
comes out of that and to nick from a
governance perspective the input that
he's contributed incredibly value and
valuable and i and i hope that he's
gained value
in reverse
thank you
thank you
okay thank you a worship and uh mark
um and obviously from the
actual
community strategy committee the same
thing i think just reinforcing what emir
said that the individual contribution
from each of the
youth councils that goes together into
one um
one big pool and actually um
comes out the other end with all that
value that has been added to um
to the group and it's great to see that
uh
we've got um a large numbers uh you know
through for the next year and all those
um diverse groups that they're going to
cover off
i don't think it was this group i think
it was a previous group we had that
speed
dating or that speed discussion night
with council the youth council was um it
was fascinating the inside
and sometimes we
we forget that the young community has a
lot of very valuable ideas
that they introduced to us when we get a
bit older you forget
um some of the uh
some of the ideas and issues that are
out there so
uh no a great thanks so um
really recommend that um just have
someone recommend that that report
i'll move the adoption of the report
okay i think you worship and um
secreted by
councillor reed
and uh thank you mark for the report
great job keep it up and i'm sure that
if nick was online he'd be saying the
same thing
all right uh moving on to our
next agenda item is our guests that have
come to chambers we've got the great
south and obviously
uh
an update on our services and we i think
we have graham
steve bobby and ben
from the great south team so welcome to
a very light chamber here um and the
the floor is yours for an update
thank you mr chair um yeah it's our
pleasure to be here and thanks very much
for your your time and this opportunity
um i'm conscious already which is the
very worst thing to do and when you're
starting a powerpoint presentation that
there's quite a lot of content in here
so we will be moving through pretty
quickly um the team will present their
respective sections
but much of the opportunity i'm sure is
just to share with you what we're up to
but also to answer any questions that
you might have so we would
welcome any questions as we go
so the the first bit is just somewhat of
an introduction to present our current
and future activity in the district
um
you know i think already about us even
better lives through sustainable
development as our is the vision
for great south for the region
um and building a connected contemporary
and competitive southern region
um through these uh core areas
of activity which we'll be touching on
today
um this is the team uh tim mckay is the
only senior leadership team member not
here today
in the interests of
our health and safety
and he's preparing for some financials
for the board next week which is
pretty critical so
this is
our funding from the gore district
in this
current year
core funding and contract funding as you
can see
our total funding just to give some
perspective is around seven million
dollars
those of you who are eagle eyed will
notice that that
pie chart is actually and sort of in
reverse
our council funding comes for about
three million dollars we get other
sources of funding of about four million
at this stage
so i'm just going to hand over to bobby
brown who's the gm of uh tourism and
events to run through her
content
cool um
nice to be here
i'm just going to whip through this
pretty quick as graeme said but of
course any questions or afterwards if
anyone wants to ask anything
that would be great
okay so probably the short version of
this is that there has been a lot of
marketing and campaigning happening
especially as people have been
dreaming of where they could go if they
could travel so it has been important to
kind of keep that consistent messaging
so southland is front of mind for people
whether they're domestic or
international
we've obviously just tried to make that
make sense with budgets and timing as
well so domestic is the focus
and in particular dried markets
the auckland flight returning to
invercargill has been useful
and we did see a good influx when that
started again but again we're just
thinking in the near future of the
markets that can come here easily
and then there's a bit of a plan for the
next 12 months about how we're going to
target new markets particularly when
borders open
so the two my uh two campaigns in market
are your due south so there's some
billboards um website stuff there
um gore is definitely included there
with um maria wise there's a teaser for
that as well as fishing
and heritage
um lots of stuff to do with media so
everybody's bombarded with um things
that they could do where they could go
and we've found that the gore posts have
been quite popular
too much there um backing up the fact
that we have been promoting and we've
seen increased traffic to the website um
so that's southwest our regional
destination site
and that that does show that people are
looking
and in particular southland does have a
lot of appeal because of open spaces
people want to connect with nature they
want to travel with family or their
partner and we do offer that
uh yeah there's lots to do with
supporting businesses and operators at
the moment um a lot of them are at this
point where as we go into year three
that they that's really struggling
um the domestic market is is not enough
to sustain a lot of them and they
haven't been able to pivot from an
international market
so we are partnering with the regional
business partner team to deliver
targeted business by business support as
well as
workshops that help improve digital
capability which this is what the slide
shows
okay just quickly through a couple of
things around how we're still trying to
develop the destination while we have
closed borders
um you will see this thing which we did
a couple of years ago and that's been
very useful because that's provided
leadership
and clarity on how we are resetting
tourism and the recovery from cobin
so we've reviewed that and that will be
reviewed again as part of the just
transitions long-term plan process
particularly as we look at
sustainability decarbonisation
and to see how businesses have actually
fared out of covid
for gore agri tourism is a really key
pillar for you guys
and it was a feature in the your juice
south campaign
food
we had a great workshop um end of last
year here uh in the rural way centre of
course is going to be quite pivotal and
being a point
um of focus
i keep saying that lots but obviously
it's a key project for you and it's
actually a key project for the region so
we're really looking forward and we keep
in touch with jim and the team quite a
lot to understand how they're
progressing and we're looking at some
joint marketing when the time is right
to help really push that product to
different markets
uh the other two things to mention is um
i'd just like to acknowledge anne and
their key person that we well i work
with um from a planning and tourism
events perspective and we've just about
we've finished two bits of work for you
guys around
looking at the rail and aviation
heritage opportunities at mandeville
and also just a bit that we received
this weekend around the brown trout
investigation
so thanks to those who were involved
they were a mixture of counsellors staff
and particularly the brown trout piece
of work had quite an extensive community
involvement
so those two bits of work we've
facilitated on your behalf and they'll
come back to council now for you to
review and to see what you'd like to do
next
yep some future opportunities as we look
forward cycling is big um but we're
seeing huge growth if you're trying to
buy a bike at the moment it's a wee bit
tricky depending on the type of bike
and sustainability
particularly around as the region looks
at decarbonisation
but also we're getting visitors who want
to give back um to the place they're
visiting or they want to understand
their impact so that is a big focus for
us and that again aligns up to other
goals with the net zero southland focus
within great south carbon mutual
advantage and of course what's happening
nationally with decarbonisation
oh still going events right so this
sector's probably been the hardest hit
so again we had a good strategy a
guiding document which has provided a
bit of leadership
[Music]
but it's really tricky because if
for event organizers we're seeing a lot
of tiredness
even if they can hold an event people's
lives are upside down at the moment so
they're thinking twice about you know
whether they want to go through the
stress or the risk attached to
volunteering to hold an event so a lot
of the cancellations we've seen have
been based on that as much as the fact
that you can only get 100 people in an
event
so it's very complex and difficult for
people to run events at the moment and i
know this is of huge importance to gore
because you are
you know
very a key events destination for us in
southland
however we have tried to support 42
events um and remember the focus here
was to look at it from
to try to use the event to bring people
to the region as much as for southwind
is to enjoy a special part of their
wildlife
and there's been quite a few obviously
based around here you've got some
fantastic event committees and
volunteers in your region which i think
you'll know
and besides that there's a whole lot of
other stuff um there i won't go all
through that but again similar to
tourism events continue to be marketed
they're part of how we position the
region
and that means we try to get it in
things like cura magazine um you know
radio
tv slots all that so that's all
happening
quite a bit
um and
yeah that just sort of talks about the
fact we're trying to cluster some events
together to lower the risk for event
organizers but to also try to get people
to stay for a whole weekend stay longer
and spend more
so there's a few examples there and a
lot more coming up
and again just to acknowledge um anne
with her role with supporting us with
allocation of the regional events fund
so this was 50 million that the
government allocated after the first
lockdown to really help regions use
events to sell the destination so ann
sits on the advisory group
with steve gibling from icc and a couple
of great south people
and we've allocated um also all of it
just about all of our allocations so far
to about 30 events from memory
but um it's been a good process and
thanks then for your contribution
still going last one so like this is
just one slide and what it is saying is
that business events are a key
part of our future
uh focus and the reason for this is that
we're seeing a lot of visiting friends
and family and these people don't often
stay in commercial accommodation so to
balance that out the business events
sector does use commercial so again it's
just part of this big and strategic
approach
so of course we've had quite a few
cancelled but to be honest it's really
positive looking for there's a lot of
interest in invercargo and southland
um as a good place to come and do
business and we're quite attractive
because of our pre and post-family
opportunities so there's lots of cool
stuff to do and we like that because
they can extend their length of stay
okay
over to
ben lewis
so i'm ben lewis gm of business services
i manage the business services team and
a team of staff working on labor market
issues and programs
um i'll just provide a bit of background
on
the services that we have in my team and
a few highlights of the last year so
we hold the great south holds the south
and contract for the national regional
business partner program
and we know that small business plays a
crucial part in itself an economy so we
have a team of three growth advisors and
they offer specialist
free business advice and support
they provide
management capability funding for small
business which is subsidised by 50
and they offer a free
business mentoring service and research
and development funding through
callaghan innovation
so on top of this sort of core work that
our team has been busy our team's been
very busy since cova delivering covert
19 advisory support to small businesses
and that included expert professional
and free advice on things like business
continuity cash flow management strategy
marketing etc
you know that was vitally important to
keep our businesses functioning through
this covered period and
we distributed distributed over 1
million of covert advisory funding
to over 400 southern businesses
from august 20 2021 sorry the team has
been responsible for a new part of
funding through the
through mb for the five harder set
regions of the south island
and that includes fioland in the south
and district rating area that doesn't
include gore and invercargill
but that's a significant amount of
funding and to date we have distributed
over 350 000 dollars to over 80
businesses
uh predominantly in the tiano area which
has been the most hard hit
look we know it's not a silver bullet
for businesses but um we're i'm really
proud of what the team's done today in
that space
um you can see
our team have also visited our growth
advisor to have visited um oh sorry i
can't quite read this
yeah there it is
our team have visited gore uh three
times from march to june 2021 so they
came here and
offered free business meetings out of
this building
and we'll be looking to do that more in
the new year as well
we didn't have as much uptake as we
would have liked but
we just think there's different
economics happening in the gore sector
as opposed to tiana and invercargill
so we think there's plenty to offer this
the score area including business
assessments capability funding r d
funding
so our team are going to work a bit more
on connecting into that area this year
um increase our presence and um we also
want to run some
business seminars and workshops although
we're very aware of what's happening
with omicron which is
not the most useful to plan at the
moment
so the other area of great south that i
manage is the labour market team
and one of the main areas of activity in
that team is the south new futures
program
we have a team of four staff working in
that space
it's a pgf funded aspirational program
which aims to build employment pathways
for youth across southland
it's ultimately focused on retaining
youth in our region
we work with young people and southland
to provide career opportunities work
with schools training providers
employers industry organizations and
government agencies
the program's been running for five
years and in 2020 increased from one to
four staff without pgf funding
we achieve our goals through
coordinate employer talks in schools
workplace visits organizing industry
sector days
employability skills workshop through
the youth passport program
and we work with employers through our
employer excellence part program as well
so we meet quite regularly with um
the staff at gore dc including uh ann
and mark it's been great to work with
you guys i'd like to
give you a bit of a shout out as well
also lisa from um hokanui
we catch up with regularly as well just
to get synergy between our organizations
and and events across southland
said just on hakanui hillary i see that
as quite a different program to youth
futures and it's quite a complimentary
program
um hakuna hironui is much more focused
on individualized one-on-one support for
high-risk students
and youth futures delivers a much larger
scale modules and events to a much
broader group of high school students
trying to catch them before they might
fall off the cliff so to speak
i'll just go into a little bit more
detail on the youth futures
ready passport program because it's
quite a big piece of our work going
forward
so we run a series of modules at high
school
students
delivered by youth future staff also in
conjunction with other local businesses
and entities such as jubilee budgeting
adventure south and active southland
the modules are focused on writing a cv
interview skills
understanding health and safety
and key employability skills of attitude
and communication teamwork personal
well-being and so forth
we've had extremely positive uh response
from aurora and james hargis to date and
wanting us to roll that out across much
more of their classes
and we have gore high school booked in
to deliver the work ready passport
program in terms two and three
and this will be delivered to senior
gateway students
um so you can also see up there some of
the other recent activity in gore
including uh just one key highlight was
the the summer of work program that the
team undertook recently it was a virtual
job fair connecting south and youth with
local jobs for
summer
it was done through online video
connections
we had over 500 vacancies through 25
employers and we placed over 60 students
into work into summer work
a couple other roles i'll just touch on
is our
primary sector workforce coordinator
role
that was a role that was funded through
mpi after covert
and we know that
you know the primary sector has had low
levels of staff retention
and attraction
and our aim has been to upskill primary
sector managers um on
an owner's on recruitment hr coaching
and legal requirements
so you can see there we had a couple of
um workshops which he had we had
actually held on gore as well
on the 4th of march and the 5th of may
on
recruitment tools and also setting up
your new employers for success
so that role was actually a one-year
role funded by mpi but it's just
finished at the end of last year
we also have our skills placement
program coordinator and that's a role
that connects newcomers like migrants
into
work opportunities
since the border has closed that role
has had a shift to focus on support for
migrants who have lived in new zealand
for some time
but we've been working in that space
we've worked the last 12 months with
over 200 migrants on a one-to-one basis
and worked with 77 partners of skilled
migrants
and through that role we've collaborated
with hakanuhuanui closing the gaps
through the job search
in 2021
and we're running a free workshop in
gore in may on intercultural
communication by communications expert
steve holloway
and just finally for me
[Music]
we also work with our central government
agencies and partners
one example is we work closely with mb
on the i'm setting up the interim
regional skills leadership group
and i'm actually a member now uh
permanent member on that group
so we provide them with regular updates
on labor market needs and and trends
and that regional skills leadership
group is currently developing a regional
workforce development plan for southland
um
and that's going to be something that's
regularly updated every year and be a
really useful document for us going
forward as a region
we also feed into local insights reports
from that group which are read at a
ministerial level regularly
and finally
the labour market attraction section
we're obviously working on how to
attract people to our region it's of
course a major challenge to our region
and it is across all regions of new
zealand
we recognize that more work needs to be
done in this space but it's worth
mentioning that we as an organization
we're not specifically funded by our
stakeholders or central government for
this activity so
we haven't had to we haven't been able
to jump into it as much as we would have
liked but
an example of our work is um last year
we ran a small advertised advertising
campaign in the new zealand herald
focused on attracting north islanders to
live in southland
um and that was quite a a good little
campaign we did so
that is it from me thanks for listening
today and over here instead
thanks ben uh kira kato steve kenny
gm strategic flow projects
just a quick update and a little bit of
a follow-up on um
our previous uh presentation later on
last visit we've um
stepped forward in a number of very
significant areas and areas that are
relevant to particularly to go
uh just a just an insight we have
developed now 13 individual
data sets for um southland across the
board and uh those data sets have all
been cleaned and now are available for
councils to use as part of their daily
planning processes we are developing a
portal to gain access to that
at present and that's just probably
another 12 weeks away
subject to completing the funding
however we are happy to work with
council planners and so on too
to
train them in the use of those tools
in the interim
just at our last visit we presented the
southland
covered scenario response and as you
know
we
we have last in the beginning of this
year
we moved ahead of where we were expected
to be in 2025 in terms of recovery
the south and region
regional economy having increased by
just over 100 million
dollars to to in excess of 6.67
billion which is very significant
primarily primarily on the strength of
the primary sector
and primary sector exports commodity
pricing and construction
that is continuing and has
put us in quite a strong position as a
regional economy in spite of covert and
the challenges associated with that
across the board as a region we are
facing housing shortage the total number
of houses
short as around 1700 as it stands today
a very significant increase in every
region gore included as you know
the average rental price in gore since
2018 has increased with more than 45
percent
the um settlement date time for
house sales has gone from has decreased
by 10 days to less than 33 days between
listing and confirmation of finance
and in many cases much less than that
um we have a waiting list for social
emergency housing of 18 applications i
think there's some recent media on that
um the the
the fact is however that gore district
has a very low level of investment
in public housing as it stands i think
it's about 5.5 per thousand population
when the average is 12.88
so there is a need for additional
servicing and investment in this area of
activity
the average ownership of houses has
increased to private ownership we had
we had a greater number of
non-occupied residential dwellings in
2018 that has changed in 2021
the detail of this work um we're going
to sit down with ann and the team
and share in detail and there will be
some significant insights to come out of
that
just uh carbon neutral advantage program
uh we presented last time the um the net
zero southland report which really sets
the
uh footprint
of our existing emissions and also a
pathway forward we have close to 100
businesses now
looking at decarbonisation and
what you may well ask why is why is this
important well today the cost of carbon
is 86.25
and that means for every tonne of carbon
you
burn you're spending 153 dollars
per tonne in emissions as as part of the
cost of that fuel so it is a very
significant
barrier to particularly export
industries and export businesses in this
area
and uh and the whole of south and
there's a generally speaking uh we've
worked with a number of a number of
local businesses to look at
decarbonisation
heartland
croydon would be one example um matera
valley dairy
and we've put some input into some of
the design of the new school
and gore so look we we have lots of
other interested areas and we plan to
run workshops and gore specifically for
businesses interested in decarbonisation
over the next
eight weeks
uh just a quick i i won't i won't
i've covered this primarily now there's
some of the examples of the
areas of focus that we have
worked on i have to just uh point out
we're also as a region looking at
hydrogen
transport fuels we are highly exposed to
the cost of fossil fuels and also
scarcity of fuel with the passage of
time so
as a as an alternative we have a unique
opportunity in southland i would say
unique
to leverage
new hydrogen transport fuel
opportunities and we're working in a
very constructive way towards
the establishment of a multi-billion
dollar fuel production facility here in
the in the province it's early days but
um however that's important the other
really critical uh fact is and you'll
note on the
powerpoint slide it says 84 dollars a
tonne for carbon it's 86.25 or 86.45
today actually
by the way um just to give you an idea
of the volatility of that that has
increased twenty dollars in about um
three weeks
um so that's a significant cost to
business
but um the other perverse effect of um
of high carbon prices is this desire to
develop and build and
plant very large carbon forests
and already uh the triggers generally
are the fifty dollars a ton
land sheep and beef land in particular
but not necessarily
exclusively above 15 degrees
farmers if they wanted to get a the best
return they could plant that in in
carbon forest and and increase their
current
return over their existing activity at
70 dollars a ton
sheep and beef on flat grazing land
converted to forestry becomes very
appealing
for individual farmers
at 104 dollars a ton
poor performing or constrained dairy
farm conversion to
carbon forest is a significant
significant um
issue
now
we we're really concerned about this we
know there are some significant
environmental and climate change
benefits of having
more forestry in each region
particularly in marginal lands riparian
strips wetlands and and
conservation state and even public other
public lands
but when you remove productive uh
farmland out of production there is a
very significant impact on the local
economy and the communities across the
board
uh we we've as i think we may have
mentioned this in our last presentation
we the first
piece of economic and social impact work
we expect to have completed on friday
this week
and we hope to map
the likely impacts across each of the
each of the regions so that you as
councils and regulators and so on have a
really clear understanding of the likely
implications of
significant conversion
unfortunately or fortunately as the case
may be depends on what side of the
equation you're looking at this
uh there are some very substantial uh
tracks of land
throughout southland that are being
airtagged for for uh exclusive um
carbon forest development and
that is quite significant in terms of
economic and
the social benefits we had examples in
2004 down the catlins area for example
with euclid planting
but it could have quite a significant
impact on
on gore district that blue area that's
shown there um you can't we can't really
see it at scale but we'll send through
the detailed
data represents about 10 000 hectares of
land potentially converted just in the
above 15 degree slope areas which is um
not quite 10
but a very very significant sorry um
a very significant part of the um of the
local area land area i should say
so we will uh we will articulate this
information we have expect to have a
wrapped up
early next month and
we'll be able to present the findings of
that
just
briefly digital mapping tools again
it's a good example we're using the
information we've developed through the
radiometric data aeromagnetic data and
also
digital elevation work to present some
of these findings and use them as
day-to-day tools
this this work is ongoing and again we
as i mentioned earlier we have around 13
different data sets available now for
council to use routinely
the other work
we've we presented to gore meeting about
three years ago
this chatham formation
work that we were interested in deep
water ground emergency water supply for
for metropolitan and other commercial
use
we have now monitored we have a team of
hydrogeologists and
geologists in their team and and we've
monitored now 2000 bore sights
we've found 36 more sites that intercept
the chatham formation
and we've been able to look at
formations that are likely to contain
quite reasonable volumes of of fresh
water at depth
the interesting part of this is that we
have modeled that and created a 3d
model part of you see a segment of it in
the top image there but
and we have discovered that the indeed
the waimea plains aquifer systems
the tara valley equivalent systems and
the
and the arrow systems appear to be
connected and are reasonably significant
uh we haven't been able to determine
water quality or otherwise at this stage
but we're working through that
particular process as we as we speak it
is reasonably significant i think for
long term
uh and that's uh just in general sense
um the advocacy work we've been involved
with is
primarily around um ty smelter
transmission pricing methodology and and
some of the interim
submission activity electricity pricing
legislative change submissions for
legislative change
we have just completed uh the
transport assessment uh economic
assessment for southland
and essentially since 2010 southland has
missed out on
direct funding or
added benefit funding around 600 million
dollars
and we're hoping to
build a business case to see greater
investment back into
into transport locally particularly
bridging and and the likes
uh you know efficient um transport
networks are critical for a very
efficient economy and and we just
presented the first
lot of findings to south and district
council a couple weeks ago and they're
keen to advance opportunities in this
area
and i guess the other area is in the
area of standards and climate change
policy there's a lot of mismatches
between some of the legislative
frameworks are present and we're keen to
see those righted
and
i guess in terms of digital services i'm
pleased to say that every square metre
of
southland down as far as the snares and
all of the offshore islands now have
ubiquitous broadband services low
latency
low
low latency high capacity
satellite services that doesn't um
doesn't mean that we can't do better
terrestrially
and at present we're just doing a
re-evaluation of the current mobile
services out to
throughout the region and we'll be able
to report back and i'm sure in our next
um
report on that on that very topic
so um i'll pass you over to graham now
um i'm sure there may be some questions
we'll follow the presentation
um can i just do a bit of a time check
in terms of how we're going for the
agenda just because
you okay for us to keep going for
yeah okay thank you i just want to make
sure um so look i think you're also
you're all very aware of this project
new zealand functional foods is our
oatmeal
plant
proposed for macaroa i won't dwell on it
too much other to say where i'm on the
board of that
representing great south shareholding
we're in a very good space but in right
in the middle of capital raise for this
project we've got some great investor
interest
um and we have plant design
land
and building design all those things
ready to go so as soon as we get an
investment which we expect to be over
the next two or three months um
confirmed um then we then we're ready to
press the button on construction
um it is as slow as as with many large
projects it's it's slipped a little in
terms of our original timing but we're
looking now at early 2023 so
um a significant project as you know
been in the pipeline for a long time
around
encouraging and supporting land use
change
in the region
i'm going to touch very quickly on this
um
and it might be a pro
content that we come back to talk to you
about it in more detail at some point
but of course mere hicks is on the
enduring oversight group for the just
transitions project so
um
so you have an expert
in terms of this process around your
around the table um
uh this is of course the process to
support the regional transition um
and uh while it was it talks about the
plan closure of the ty point aluminium
smelter we knew we know with the
announcement that they intend to stay
open that the government commitment
is unwavering regardless and the just
transition process will continue to seek
diversification opportunities for the
region
so i'm going to whiz through quite a bit
of this stuff because it's detail um the
governance group that um mayor hicks is
part of includes
these sort of represent the
representation from the wider region
um
and sectors within the region
um we are an observer on the enduring
oversight group but bobby um next to me
is actually one of the project leads
which will which we'll talk to
um the work plan is an 18-month work
plan uh and our our project
is the sorry i think as the long-term
planning and capability on behalf of the
region which i think i believe we've
probably talked to you about before
um
i think i'm gonna whiz through this a
little bit um and but um and just focus
on our project
um
[Music]
bobby's photo taken last week bobby yes
um so we are leading the long-term
planning work streak on stream on behalf
of the region we've received the
contract which is funded by mb through
just transition process
and i want to make it really clear and
it's really important to us that this is
a
great south house to contract but this
we're doing this on behalf of the region
this is a regional project
by the region and for the region we just
happen to have the contract to lead it
and so bobby has been seconded for 18
months
to lead this work stream
these this is what the long-term plan
kind of looks like and struck
structurally um but i was through
this a little to talk to show you
it's a bit small we'll send this through
um that actually we've identified and
socialized with some of our key
stakeholders
um the five primary areas of um activity
and if i'm honest with you i even i
can't read those from back here so i
won't
take take you through these but i do
think if if at some point we take the
opportunity to come back and present it
more thoroughly
um that that may be useful to you so
apologies um for whizzing through
look look at th this is really the end i
just wanted to comment on the fact that
obviously the draft statement of intent
for from great south
um is with council for consideration
alongside our or with our other
shareholders
so i know you've had that draft um
and we
we i won't
talk talk to that other than um you know
we look forward to the feedback soon on
the draft the content of the draft as
well as the the budget that we've put
forward
to council
[Music]
these
just i think just one more slide these
are the priorities regional leadership
diversifying the economy supporting
business growth promoting the region and
importantly leading environment
environment and climate change which the
team has touched on today
right so that's us
quite a lot of content there thank you
for your time we're happy to answer any
questions
yeah thank you
the great south team
um quite a lot of information a lot of
facts and figures and uh a lot of
diverse diverse topics amongst that so
um i'll open it up to the uh
the
committee and councillors whether it's
any questions from the floor
uh thanks mr chair and thank you to
great south team for that presentation
it's
pretty slick and
there's a lot going on so really good to
get that
big picture big picture of you
just a couple of questions and i think
this one was to ben
talking about the rslg and the insight
reports that they do and present up the
line to cabinet
ministers um how widely are those shared
it's a very good question actually i
know
slightly more than me um
it's probably a question for envy is in
a way and how widely they're spreading
those are they
are you talking about ministerial people
or i guess i'm asking from an rsl south
and rslg group are they sharing those
only with mb
or do they get a local viewing um i look
uh my understanding is uh until now
they've been shared with me and from
through mb to the minister minister so
ministers actually see them i don't
believe they have been distributed
locally
but i think they absolutely should be
and i suspect there's no particular
reason why they haven't been other than
they've just got into a process so we'll
take that away okay
okay and um steve uh really interesting
to know there's been quite a bit of work
completed around that you know very deep
aquifer network that we've got there
what sort of depth are we talking about
there
uh well look it does vary depending on
the particular location but generally
speaking between 120 and 205 meters
right
yep so it's quite deep
uh well actually it is uh it is deep in
a southland context but it's very deep
in in terms of water
exploration and abstraction um
and other regions and
and internationally
okay
and just on the the um
sort of the the broadband capability
across across the province and and i
know there's been a whole lot more added
but
you talked about some of
the challenges still out there
and and i guess one of the challenges i
find on a on a personal basis
particularly from between here in
invercargill on state highway 1 there's
probably 15 to 20 k's where there's
nothing available
um and
it's quite frustrating
oh look um
you know me hicks we've been working on
this for a long time and you've been
working on that as well uh it is
extremely frustrating with the
deployment of
mobile black spots and wireless
broadband has been pretty slow
um fibre is gradually catching up and
really what we're trying to do now is to
identify absolute the areas that haven't
been covered
it's a centrally managed process
and
i guess
we're the vehicle to provide input
locally and we'll certainly be reporting
back to council on that we're
we're keen to see that those black spots
and and nulls in and connectivity are
filled
great thanks
thank you mr chair um i just have a
couple of questions there's one for
bobby
in terms of um
tourism has it had a great effect on
gore
the
the coven has is
that had a great effect
yeah i think it depends on which part of
the tourism sector you look at so
obviously the lockdown that affected all
businesses
but your visitors were primarily
domestic and quite strongly aligned to
events as well
what we're trying to do is promote
people to travel around the region in
different ways so in places like gore
that have accommodation in you know
resources and infrastructure like that
are quite important to then help
disperse you know to other places
so yeah i would say yes similar not as
bad as some other parts of the region
like fiordland and which were heavily
reliant on international
thank you
just another question i
i see that the government is looking at
the skills for
people that are immigrating is that
going to have an effect
for
our agricultural sector and bringing
people into south
the reality by and large is that
we need skills across the board we have
an aging workforce and we have aging
work
business ownership
uh it's implicit that we do have more
more skills and more youth entering the
primary sector particularly agriculture
look there is
the the pathway to to
a permanent residency hit will make a
difference
um but this is a total numbers game
really
across the board and i think we still
need um quite substantial
new workforce a you we track
one of ben's team actually tracks the
number of jobs and types of jobs on a
weekly basis and typically we have
between 700 and i think 935
jobs available in the region
and we're certain that most many of
those are not being placed not being
filled i should say
we have a competitive workforce but one
of the biggest single
issues uh particularly for retention of
youth at the moment is the cost
and non-availability of housing
uh it's not
and so that is a
that's a massive challenge that we have
to address um
and unfortunately we have some fairly
strong evidence to show that young
people are moving away
for that very reason and we've got to
address that they're the sort of people
we want to retain in our communities
and families as well so
yeah it's not a straightforward process
but hopefully we're making progress in
the right direction
great thank you just have one other
question regarding carbon farming
is
unless there's a change in the
government's thinking it's not going to
change is it can you
somehow enforce this for our district
yes i think the um the opportunity and
the challenge for southland is that 58
of our land area is next in actual fact
conservation of state or public lands
um our view is that um in section 4 and
other lower conservation value areas
that should be permanent or
forest focused on these particular areas
likewise in farmland we we think that
the effort should be focused on wetlands
riparian strips and marginal lands
the unfortunate
the unfortunate situation is there's
nothing to prevent in many cases
large-scale forestry development
and
unless
there is some sort of
regulatory framework put in place to
address some of those issues
we can see significant change
and unfortunately despite the very best
of intentions of
communities at large it comes down to
individual landowners making individual
decisions
um that affect them individually and so
you can't socialize that
we've seen it with fishing quota and
other activities where local communities
felt they could
manage the process and nobody would sell
their quota and that just doesn't happen
so
we're mindful of the effect that it can
have
it has two major effects based on other
areas and one is that you have an
amalgamation of smaller lots so you have
fewer fewer ratepayers across the board
you have
smaller communities that affect
schooling
affects all other
mission you know critical health
services etc
um so really what we're trying to do is
illuminate this topic early
so that we can have a proper and
balanced conversation around the effects
and advocate accordingly and one of
those effects is of course water yield
from
forestry taking up water yes
as well very very significant changes in
all of those natural resource uptakes
and so on
just just on that point i guess
there's a good comment you made there
steve around you know communities
needing to have a conversation on this
but
like
this is ring roll out as we speak
and i'm just looking at that photo up
there and probably
from a similar vantage point there's
going to be quite a large scale
carbon farm
in that area yes so
time is of the essence for for this
community and for all communities to get
their heads around what this means for
us and and i know that
i spent a wee bit of time in
southern south and looking at what
happened with the eucalypts in the 90s
and
it's not nice
in terms of
effect on community it may well be
good in economic terms but certainly in
social terms it's not particularly good
at all
no that's that's the that's the central
issue really
so any other questions from the floor
there
just um in regard to the uh the draft
statement of intent um
a query and
the elected members do have the ability
to be able to put input into that
in regard to any changes or
um
yeah so well i'm
sorry and i'm not sure of the exact
process that you're you have here in
terms of socializing that and giving
feedback with the other shareholders so
can i so ask you that
yeah
so um if our elected members have any
comments on that it would be
nice to hear those so that the team at
great south can hear those today
um but if you're all happy with it
that's great and from my perspective of
working with great south for the past
year
i think we've made
incredibly good
inroads into
school districts representation and all
of the areas that they've discussed so
i'm actually very happy with how we're
going
and i've mentioned from time to time to
a chief executive like these things that
in our patch we want to do better and
when we can do them those things better
um great south will be able to
do a better job as well for us
and i'm working with sonia on some of
those things and so i expect to see
quite a bit of change on our side
i'm coming which then
you know be great to talk about the way
forward with some of those things so for
me and my team it's a really big thank
you because
i'm at the start you know it was hard
work for me trying to work out where we
were going and what was happening but i
think we've done well and um so thank
you from from myself so yeah for elected
members if you've got any feedback for
graham and his team
it would be great to hear that
so so just just in terms of the
statement of intent so it has its first
hearing in a public setting here for
gore district but then
all of this will be confirmed
through a council meeting so it will be
um an opportunity for everybody to have
a an input into it can happen there yeah
yeah no thank you and thanks for those
comments and we've also enjoyed the
relationship and i think it is
the bottom line is it's producing better
outcomes
so that's that's
yeah it's great thank you
that's that probably answers process and
questions
any other questions any discussion from
the floor there or just um
council read
thank you mr chair just a comment really
not a question um
i was quite interesting to see
so many um
motorbikes and camper vans come down
through even though there was no burt
munro
so obviously your campaigns are working
and people are quite happy to make their
own fun
in a nice way
thank you we think that our campaigns
are effective and there's a number of um
both hard data but often just anecdotal
ways that we we hear that where people
say we've seen that or we've come
because of that um but that's a very
good example of the power of events and
bobby touched on this bef before
and and the momentum that creates and
the fact that people are still coming
because they wanted to have that break
and that holiday despite the event not
being on
you know it's good evidence of of just
the momentum as i say that those
those events create so
yep we
i think it's really important that we
keep um
we keep promoting the region in a
targeted and appropriate way even
through these very difficult times um
we've got to do two things one
demonstrate to our businesses and our
regions and our communities that we are
continuing to support them uh and for
some businesses that's actually
critically important that they see that
we are doing that and the other thing is
there will be people making choices
about coming way fewer than they were
before but um they will still make
choices about coming maybe but not now
but maybe in six months or nine months
or 12 months and that's why continuing
to promote and profile the region
is critically important so you don't
actually lose your your your place in
the mind of consumers and travelers
thank you
any further discussion from the floor
there
uh just one one question for myself um
in regard to that primary uh sector that
workforce um
plan or program or work that had been
done and it's obviously the mpi of
c-step funding
who's picked that up like where has that
gone to
who carries that now because obviously
if we're getting 6.6 billion out of our
primary sector and as we know
in the climate today they are carrying
us yeah
so we it's a good question that go to
like where's that ended up who yeah so
um the workforce coordinator role it was
initially set up to help with um
all the roles that were going to be lost
in tourism to transition them into
the primary sector out of covert back in
2020 that didn't eventuate it just
that idea just didn't didn't happen
so the funding um has has not gone into
the coordinator role but part of funding
has been picked up by
a small company through lindsay statford
and she will be delivering some of those
um
presentations that i mentioned before to
the to the primary sector community so
part of it is going to be carried on
which is which is good to see
okay
so so who's driving that bin
oh sorry who's driving where that goes
the
the prime minister
the funding and that
that project has had how does that
connect with the community
um do you know well i guess we're not
driving it is per se but it's good to
see a part of the program is still
delivered
um it is it is an unfortunate thing
where we have these contracts with
government where they do um finish at
times yeah so it's an mpi decision i'm
assuming to continue to fund that part
of it that we we had no
right of exam
the actual
rural economy contributes just over four
billion to the total economic activity
of the region
um and the other elements of the um
of our economy made up by
other commodities
and uh sorry other services
and construction and so on yeah
okay
still 70 percent
and the the only other point was that
those data sets obviously with um their
ceo here we will get access to those
because
the fact we make a lot of assumptions
around what's happening within our
community we
we tend to
crystal wall and say we think houses are
doing this and we think that that's
happening we think but obviously those
data sets will confirm or
or non give us a non-confirmation of
what we're actually thinking so they
when are they going to be the next three
months is it 12 12 weeks
look the um the the housing report data
is uh is completed um we are just
waiting on some march end figures which
we'll introduce and and unfortunately
some of the
uh annualised figures are based on may
end figures so we're just
we'll pass that over to ann
i think with any of these activities
including the economic activity
during periods of quite significant
change you've got to revisit them very
quickly
we have another
revisit of the economic and demographic
data in april
and
and these will just be available
progressively throughout the year in
terms of land use change and so on uh
we're currently
tackling work on a six monthly basis
and where there's detectable land use
change where we um
we'll be able to indicate that within
your reach within the
uh district without any major difficulty
okay
thanks steve
um if there's no further discussion
there thank you very much for that
detailed presentation um a lot of
information uh
really interesting times we live in
you never know what you're going to wake
up to some mornings but um we just got
to keep pushing forward and there's uh
some some really good uh projects and
and uh developments on the horizon there
so
if i could just have someone move that
that report was received our council
read the second council dixon
thank you
thanks
uh the next agenda item is uh the
welcome plan and i believe the community
strategy manager and
we've got uh
there's mark still i think mark is
probably still there
i think they're going to lead us through
this um i see that uh councillor grant
had had some importance of this too too
nick but i'm not sure he's
online so
but if you guys want to lead us through
that
okay so in front of you is the completed
welcome plan
um this is here for your information
our role has been very much a
facilitation role as this plans a
collaboration between guru district the
newcomers community immigration new
zealand ministry of ethnic communities
and the humans rights commission
there will be
a large range of organizations that are
involved in the implementation of this
as well as other community members and
groups
so the the approach we've taken with
this is very much a community-led
approach so not a top-down it's a
bottom-up approach from people that have
been newcomers in the community
and who have been mobilizing themselves
as groups um to achieve things for
themselves but actually require a
greater voice in their community so the
process has really been about
understanding their voice their
experiences
and some of the potential solutions that
they see
to make life better here to enjoy their
life in ghoul district but ultimately
for us so that we retain these people
that they don't just come here and be
here for several years and then leave
so
[Music]
we have we held a workshop we also did
some survey work
and through that has been the
development of the plan
and i guess the four things that have
really come out strongly in this is the
integration assistance that's required
the need for better local community
information for newcomers to our
district
bridging the cultural divide
and
the involvement in activities
we've had some excellent feedback at a
national level on the plan because i um
we are leading the way
with this plan
uh
and i guess because we've taken a
community-led approach more than a
top-down and developing it with agencies
the agencies are an important part of
this plan but it's now that we actually
have it from a community perspective
i have given you today
a
a document that actually shows the
submissions that we received and those
submissions had have been
viewed and
the changes and taken changes from those
for the plan and the reference group
have done that
going forward we're in intending to
further develop the reference group but
we're in this phase of
consolidating the approach really
so the next thing that we'll be looking
to do is to prioritize the high actions
and start to work on those so the
intention is that i'll continue to
facilitate
the group um but mark will be leading
the work now mark i know you were there
do you want to make some comments
about this being very well received
i believe we're the only council that
has up to this point produced a
community-led
welcome plan and there are
as of today 20 different councils
involved in the welcoming communities
program some of them have not had a
chance to
next month and we share our approach so
that
they can possibly take the same pathway
as we did
it's been very well received as they say
yeah very positive
um
thank you anna mark
uh obviously i'll open up for the
discussion but uh before i
sort of go into that um i'm aware of the
amount of work that has gone into this
with the various um
outside groups and plus the work that's
been pushed through from
with the assistance of the council
um
and the the outcome document is is you
know it's really good like it you need
to be complimented on the standard that
has been produced here it's
aligns with the other documents that
we've been receiving sort of over the
last year through
through um their
community strategy or through the
through the work that you're doing
so you need to be complimented on that
um there is some good uh feedback there
for the counselors if they go through go
through that um and have a
read through there there's
quite a lot of dialogue
around various issues
but
i'll open it up to the counsellors for
discussional questions counselor read
thank you mr chair i haven't had an
opportunity to look through this one yet
anne so forgive me if i
miss something but big congratulations
to you and mark
it's it's a very good clear concise
document it's written in plain english
so that there's no
you can actually you want to read it
it's a really good plan and i'm
delighted that our council is the first
one to pick up and run with it
i did have a few comments and i'm
prepared to be
told that yes we are doing that one of
the things that i see the um the people
who could be involved there's
unless i have missed it um no mention of
churches
i know that in the community for a lot
of newcomers sometimes that's their
first port of call
so some of the members on the working
group are connected to church groups
good um
but this is the next phase as counselor
readers actually bringing in other
groups and what we're anticipating is
more a hub and spoke
a model going forward so there's going
to be some projects that relate more to
some groups than others and so what
we're wanting to do is mobilize more
people
around the group that keep the reference
group but then some people put their
hand up and said we would like to
participate in a particular project
so we expect each project might have you
know six to eight ten people and that's
when some of those groups will get more
involved but there is connections
already there
and the workshop actually was held
within one of the churches but i think
one of the important things about this
is
we're looking forward to when we have
our community rooms here because
actually
we want to have spaces that are
inclusive for everyone
yeah
thank you ian
just a couple of wee thing um you're
talking about retaining
people in the community
and
to my way of thinking the one person who
is often the hub of the wheel between
family work and partners is the female
in the family
and i just i know they quite often feel
isolated and when they do come to our
communities um
you know kids go to school hubby goes to
work
and they're on their own so is there a
specific plan going forward for those
people to be
engaged with and taken
just sort of
under the wing of some people in the
community
mark do you want to comment on that or
do you want me
to thanks man
so
we have um somebody on our working group
or reference group has
taken um
this direction to
contact a number of people who are
experiencing isolation in the district
and to meet on a regular basis
every week for a coffee and a chat
um and there's been a really successful
group which has grown in numbers of late
and uh
to see
in terms of isolation as well what we're
hoping to do as part of this plan is to
set up a
database
which
real estate agents churches schools
can contribute to by acting as a conduit
and connecting those newcomers if they
wish to share their details with us and
then we can approach them and
moving forward and make sure that they
don't feel that sense of isolation
thank you mark once again
congratulations it's a really really
good document
oh sorry
go ahead
i thank you mr chair i reiterate what um
councillor reed has said it is a very
well written document and
congratulations for that i know a lot of
work has gone into it i'm wondering um
how
i know we're in the process of sitting
setting up
neighborhood watch groups
whether
those people in the street that are
nominated to be the spokesperson could
be involved in this somehow
as well
so we're not missing out on people in
isolated areas
i think that's a great idea and
we're in discussions with cnt around you
know what projects we'll work together
on so i'm sure those things will start
to develop as we as we get into the
implementation phase
and i just want to add my
congratulations this is stunning
it's a stunning document there's been
some real
heavy-duty work gone and behind the
scenes to get it to this point in time
and here only to be congratulated for
that
i guess
a question i have is around
how do we
share this information with our wider
community
um i guess we're
this is this is focusing really on well
absolutely on newcomers um but
for that to be successful um we've got
to have the buy-in of those
like me that have been here all our
lives so how do we do that
so we've already
started having some conversations about
which comes under that area of
integration
of
what exists already here that we can
mobilize to introduce newcomers to
so i mean that's quite a large piece of
work
and
you know we're yet to develop the detail
around that but we're certainly starting
to have some conversations around it as
far as the actual plan goes like it will
be on the council website um it will be
available but i think what's going to be
of more interest to the community and
the newcomers are the individual actions
and how we proceed with those
yeah yeah
absolutely but i think um there'll be a
large section of our community who'll be
interested in this and they'll be
actually
stunned to see
the depths and the quality of this so
while i'm
very mindful of costs and
and whatever digital is
is the way to go it has to be there but
but also hard copies would be really
good but just with this one just be able
to pick it up and open it up is
invaluable so i don't think we can
don't we can we can lose the
um
the input that a
hard copy can have
and we've had some discussions around
that as far as
a welcome pack
that
some people would like that to be
digital but a lot of people would like
that to be
into a hard copy but you've also got to
consider the language
issues we might have as well so those
are things that we'll be working through
over the coming months to get solutions
that we think will work for the
community
chancellory um thanks mr chair um just
down to the welcoming packs um a good
point anne about the fact that you know
the digital's not always the best way to
go but
included in those packs is exactly what
just information
sorry
so it
it depends a lot on our community
but we don't want to be reinventing the
wheel so there are already some good
databases that
have a lot of the information around
clubs and services so what we'll be
wanting to do is direct people to the
appropriate places
we're certainly not going to
re-do work that already exists
yeah i understand that so it can it it
varies but what we'll be wanting to do
is give them a sense of place for a
starter what is gordo street you know
how does it operate all of those types
of things i mean there's a a range of
initiatives that have been discussed
should we be having you know some sort
of um whether it's a welcome afternoon
tea for newcomers so that you know they
can meet locals first off
and so there's a whole raft of things
that can be put in there but it'll be
general information around the district
and then pointing to them two locations
where the other information already
exists
which is a little bit like the little
booklet that somebody just held up
before
which has been done with the focus
audience of our 65 plus market so we'll
do something that's with the focus of a
newcomer what do they actually need what
are the questions that they want to know
and there is a project um with gore nz
website that sonya is leading and and so
we've been talking and thinking about
what else do people need
before they actually get here but then
once they're here yeah
thank you anne
when i one thing i wondered whether or
not
if included in those packs physically is
the opportunity to perhaps have a free
pass to the aquatic center
mr eo and possibly like
movie tickets or something like that
just because quite often families are so
caught up in the rush of arriving new
jobs new schools
and there's always that plan to go
somewhere but if you've got a free
pass even just for the kids or something
wonderful idea
thank you and the other thing i want
i see first up here on the list the
action was english language lessons
and i wondered will that also include
translation of some of our local
colloquialisms
so mark might like to comment on that
because he's already done quite a bit of
work in the space
with respect to the english lessons
themselves we have actually formed a
teaching collective
who are all international english
language testing qualified
they share resources and promote
themselves locally and provide that
english lesson service which is growing
day by day
in terms of translation one of those
teachers has offered to do that
translation in chinese to english free
of charge and indeed offers
english lessons free of charge as well
which has been hugely valuable
and
an opportunity for newcomers coming to
town to walk around the town and be
introduced to the different
points of interest by people
who currently live here one of the
councillors has already put their hand
up to do that
we also
have supported companies looking to
attract
employees into their area by meeting
with them at the
um and just giving them
an overview of what to expect
and that's been hugely successful
actually in attracting at least three
people to the area
and just being proactive so
that's what's currently happening
already
thank you
so much further discussion from the
floor there
nothing
no i think
we've probably covered off everything
that needs to be
stated regarding a well-presented
document i i do agree with um his
worship that
uh it's a good show car a showcase
document that could be in hard copy and
maybe it is up to um
up to the councillors themselves if they
get copies of this that they actually go
out and place them in the various places
that they believe would be um
appropriate for people to access because
we all know
uh enough people we're all embedded in
the community and we know where people
pick up
pick up the
closest thing to them to have a read
while they're waiting in a in the
dentists or the the doctors or
the theatre or wherever so
um i think that would be a good
a good suggestion but we're also mindful
of the financial implications with that
um
so
all we need now is someone to
someone can move that that uh this
report is received as it is
councillor reed and secretary councillor
dixon
and uh thank you once again to mark and
ann and all the other
various groups
and uh individuals i know um from
some of the the workshop that i attended
there was a lot of individuals that were
there from
uh diverse cultures um fascinating and
and really keen on
having an input so yeah
they can all pat themselves on the back
of what we've got here today
okay moving on we have ab uh
four which is the ready for living
progress report i see kylie down the
back so
welcome kylie
sorry mr geo just i i'm not sure who's
looking after zoom but we've got
somebody waiting to come in
okay okay i'll be the
80-plus
yeah if
we're happy to
move through we can get
martin to put that through if
we could go to the next agenda item and
come back to four if councils are happy
with that
now you yep there
we'll continue with
technology we're trying to be too smart
for ourselves so
it always happens
we'll continue with ready for living
kylie
hi everyone um so i've just got a report
about oh am i really allowed ready for
loving and everything that's been going
on in the last six months i've been at
council now in the role for six months
we've received lots of positive feedback
and i'd like to highlight some of our
successes so um i've just
picked a few points from the report
[Music]
read out so we've now got two years
confirmed funding from ph bakery trust
to continue
my rowers coordinator
i'll go
over so we've
had some feedback on loneliness has been
identified as an issue from community
members
however it's been hard to identify the
lonely people
for us
there are a large number of social
groups available for older people so
ready for living produce the booklet
that you've got in front of you
a guide to local services and
connections for older people
to help the community be aware of what
what's available so it's covering things
from medical services support at home
transport social opportunities and
support organizations
so that has gone out last week we
started publicity and
from today it's in the newspaper next
week i think i'm on the radio tomorrow
so that's going to be
good so we've taken it to senior
citizens and rsa luncheon
so there's lots and distribution as well
as at the library in our main
areas medical centers
so we've
placed them around
so it's been a cool project to get
completed
um over 80s free parking
we've had over 160
people receive their permit so that's
from
last community strategies meeting or
might have been the one before last one
and that that was
brought through so it's been um
really good to see people picking it up
and real good feedback
around that too
um as a coordinator we got contracted by
reap to run better digital futures for
seniors class so we did some computing
classes for older people
last year which was
an interesting experience let's say
um
i'm not continuing doing that at the
moment
and we also have been advocating for the
older people
in several ways but when the vaccine
pass came out there was a bit of
uncertainty around how the older people
would get it
so we looked at
before we heard the pharmacists were
doing it because it seemed to come in
quite late
when that knowledge became public so i
organized um different agencies to get
together and help
that and promoted that in the newspaper
and
on the radio too
so that was awesome and i also helped at
the library doing vaccine passes as well
just one last point that i'd like to
highlight so international older persons
day we had some awesome plans
including a mural tea party that we were
hoping to invite councillors to
which was something that was over um
overseas would seem but of course with
covid we had to
stop our plans so
we did have four page editorial on the
end sign for international older persons
day
um we were hoping for two pages and we
had so many businesses support we had
four pages of content
come up at the last minute so that was
awesome knowing that the community is on
board with the project and knowing
about supporting older people so
yeah
that's um thank you kylie
um
obviously there'll be a couple of
questions from the discussion from the
floor there in regard to some of their
successes the
uh
someone will probably ask it anyway but
the 80 year old
parking what what number
do we have or how many
people do 800
so it's only about a 25
oh wait how many had licenses yeah
that's not in this report there was what
was there 800 people total maybe and
i can't remember now 500 licenses i had
that number on the top of my head but i
didn't i'm just interested to see how
many people have taken it up i know that
i did speak to an 89 year old the other
day who hadn't taken it up and was was
oblivious to the fact that it existed so
um yeah they will be getting it now but
um yeah it's
should should we do a uh follow-up like
if we if we re-advertised or i know we
did some media around at communications
we haven't at this stage but it was
something we could probably look at and
do around this booklet i know when i was
talking to people and we're flicking
through it came up for a couple of
people and i've got a couple of permits
to deliver
around to help older people as well as
that some of those people have the
wheelchair card already
and we didn't have those numbers divided
we couldn't get that data
and as well several of those people
aren't driving
um so it's a balance of yeah the stats
not being very accurate as well with who
decides to
have the pyramid um but i still think
160 still a good a very good uptake so
yeah yeah
um
i'll open it to the floor for discussion
well yeah
councilory
thank you mr chair um
if this is really good it's
a lovely wee booklet and i'm sure it's
going to be picked up in red and and
obviously that's something that could
also be included in the welcoming pack
isn't it
lots of good things happening in the
community
um to do with
the older older people that we have in
town
um
just lovely to know that they're being
looked after so well
so
yeah job well done thank you
it's reassuring as one gets older
i didn't like to say that
well done kylie it's um just fantastic
and just continues to build on
what has been a really good foundation
and goes from strength to strength yeah
well done thanks
thank you mr chair kylie um i just i
know there was some discussion around
housing about looking at older people
that in a big big home
in the area and
talking to them about moving to a
smaller home or has that happened or
i'll pass that to anne she's
moved on to housing for me
um now says no genius
the discussions that i'm having around
housing is really in the social housing
space
uh
i guess one of the things is that
there's a lot of older people that love
their big homes
and don't see the need to move to
smaller housing which is always going to
be a challenge for poor
but no we don't have any initiative at
the moment around housing making changes
from
an older person's point of view
we have been having some discussions
with the current services that are here
and just building an understanding
of what is here and what's the demand
um any further discussion there no look
i'm happy to move that the report be
received mr chair
and
see the council dixon damn
like that's uh it is
very very very informative um we've got
some great got some great um
great initiatives on the go and that
have been uh haven't actually been
implemented so you
leading the way there
um the only query i did have just before
we moved that was that
how often do we update that like what's
the
that'll be like a living document
because you'll have to yeah you know
every year there'll be further services
or changes
so i think we're talking six months a
year depending especially after this
first one there might be a few changes
and more feedback from the community so
we are looking for community feedback on
how we continue with it and the best way
to have it
produced so we will continue to update
but a very informative document and
great as you say to go on that welcome
welcome pack as well so
i thank you for that uh kylie
i'll move on to our next
because
martin where are these
80 plus
the next generation is the
the 80 plus free swimming at the aquatic
centre so um we've got martin there
oh
and kyle sorry
okay
here we go
so uh
kylie again and martin
there can
lead us into this
um
i'll do the proposal but martin's here
to answer all the questions
the hard stuff
um
so our proposal that has came through
our steering group but lots of
community feedback um is that
around the free swimming for over 80. so
our proposal is to allow people 80 years
or older to use gore aquatic center with
no charge to swim
and attend equifit classes
swimming in the aquatic exercise is a
great low impact exercise for older
people with many health and well-being
benefits
many studies
have proven swimming in aqua aerobics
have many benefits for older people
including
improving cardiovascular vascular health
reduced risk of falls improves sleep
boosts mental health and is on
as gentle on the joints the pool is a
point of social connections for many
older people which adds further benefit
for their well-being local pool staff
see older people making these
connections on a daily basis
free swimming for over 80s will
encourage a larger number of older
people to swim
and helping them maintain health
the times a day older people swim are
generally not peak times as they aim for
the quieter times when children aren't
about
and the free swing we would acknowledge
the contribution to our community that
many long-standing ratepayers have made
the proposal includes free swimming and
aquafit but not the swimming master
classes
so some stats that are getting old now
our next census mustn't be far away
um from 2018 census data the gore
district had
2
616 people over 65 and 750 over 80. the
number of users over 80
attending this centre is hard to
determine exactly as casual users are
only classified as over 60. um so in the
past year
101
389 seniors over 60 have used the pool
the previous year
total was four thousand eight hundred
and three
so yeah
so the goal aquatics has
20 swimmers currently over 80 years with
annual memberships um
that
this equates to an annual income at
eight there uh 8 000 per annum the
annual membership is 400
individually and there's some breakdown
of the pool's income
and what comes from over 60s in that
report
um there are not many other aquatic
centers in new zealand that have free
swimming for over 80s so it would be
great to be a leader in implementing
this
council is one that offers free swimming
for the over 80s
um so our proposal is to provide aquatic
center users aged 80 years or older with
free access to swimming and aquatics
classes the implementation will be quite
simple
around their
centres staff just checking a id
quickly on the way past or if they have
a membership
just citing some formal id
and we'd do a report back after six
months of implementation to review
number of people over 80 that have used
this
phil
yeah thank you carly is um martin do you
want to add anything else to that
yeah
[Music]
um
um
um
uh thanks martin
um
so counselors we have a uh proposal
there which obviously will go through
recommendation through to full council
but um is there a questions discussion
uh councillor reed
thank you um council macphail
it's a great idea i'm really excited to
see this
just
as long as the money is not an issue for
the
our income
but
i could see that this apart from
anything else from the well-being point
of perspective with people being able to
go physically
look after themselves but also have
contact with other people and i think
that's really important so
yeah brilliant idea and initiative and
i'll be very happy to move that as a
move that report to take to council for
ratification
council dixon
i'm
thank you
mr chair
i'm very happy to second
the recommendation i just i think it's a
great initiative and i think those
people that are 80 actually deserve to
have free access and pay rates for many
many years most likely in the district
it's just something that council can do
for them that's like a thank you and and
it's good for them to keep fit in their
well-being so happy to see that
thank you
and um yeah mr just echo the comments
that have already been made i very much
support this i think a point that was
raised about income
i think with
one of the challenges councillors have
and it's a perennial challenge is
balancing costs against value and i
think that this particular item
is quite starkly weighed on the side of
value as opposed to cost
so i very much support it
thank you councillors i think we've
probably passed that um
motion there that proposal will go
through to full council i agree with the
commentaries that have been stated uh
obviously the green prescription that
comes from swimming mental health
physical health um
you know there's there's all those
attributes that go along along with the
uh social aspects
and hopefully if i'm still here when i'm
80 i'd be quite happy to go and have a
dip and your worship i think you'd be
having a pair of speedos somewhere
wouldn't you
in
but no great
a great a great initiative there um and
i'm sure that we'll uh have some
favorable support when we get through
the main council as well uh thanks kylie
and thank you martin keep up the good
work there i know we're working through
some
um difficult uh
times and restrictions and various
things and the crew are doing a great
job i was in there last week and uh yeah
now everything seems to be functioning
well so thanks very much
um
moving on
uh we're kylie again uh our age
friendly business uh initiative the afb
um
if you want to lead us into that
yep so
we're just going over
re-establishing the age-friendly
business initiative and i did find that
we had put it in our first report when
we were looking at
bringing the project to council ready
for living but i'll just go over the
initiative
for you and the age friendly business
initiative recognises
school district businesses and
organizations that aspire to be age
friendly the initiative is part of the
ready for living project
the a trini business framework and
toolkit for gore district has been
developed jointly with the gore district
older community members businesses and
services
the initiative supports school district
businesses services
providers to adapt to an aging
population and to better meet the needs
of all customers and clients
participation
participating businesses focus on
business self-improvement in four areas
environment and accessibility
communications and information respect
inclusion
and product and services the aim is to
create a business environment that is
accessible a customer service experience
that is inclusive and respectful and to
offer products that meet the needs of
all customers and clients whatever their
age life stage and ability businesses
can show their customers clients and
community that they are committed to a
journey of learning self-assessment and
continuous improvement and support
older and support older people in the
community the age-friendly business
initiative is an easy self-assessment of
how a business meets the needs of older
people as well as the whole community
being age friendly is good for customer
and client satisfaction for the business
bottom line and the customer retention
and growth
why do businesses need to be
age-friendly businesses can no longer
take the 50-plus aged customers and
clients for granted more are living
longer and staying healthier
as the older population grows so will
its spending power
and so examples of what businesses could
do and some have occurred and some ideas
um provide appropriate appropriately
height seating
um and that includes arm rests not being
too low
doors easy to use with pull push signs
or even automatic if possible
large font on things like brochures um
it was even mentioned in the group the
wii
barcodes in the supermarket with prices
on many people have to put their glasses
on so that was a point water
not
making assumptions of what you think
older people want
such as always wanting the cheapest
item such as gym shoes or a printer
um not yelling or talking slowly to them
products um so paul at the theater
changed some times and movies to
mid-afternoon and he's got a good
following of
people that can come in those time slots
um giving options to change the
hairstyle not just thinking that they'll
permanently want that same perm with
something brought up and having an
answer message that's clear and concise
um so seven businesses have taken this
initiative up included connected eastern
southland
gore counselling center
ministry of social development new world
high b st jones theatre and triton
with the
pending omni current chrome outbreak
i wrote this a week ago
um we have made this decision not to
make a firm plan on when to start
publicity of the a trini business
originally it was gonna be starting in
february till june was planned publicity
for the radio newspaper business events
facebook and antenna
it is important that all
council facilities are age friendly and
complete the recognition process to show
that council is committed to lead and
acknowledge age friendly
to support older people
um interventional sessions are planned
to have with all the council facility
managers
businesses have identified to start
approaching
have been identified to start
being approached
and will be given a flyer with
information about age-friendly business
and this will be followed up with
communication and meetings
ready for living will reassess the
situation and have everything in place
to start when it's safe to do so
um
so it's a simple four-step process of
self-assessment creating an action plan
filling in two documents to receive an
aspiring to be age-friendly logo and
reassessing progress yearly to make
changes
um
the coordinator can assist businesses
as they work through the program there's
no deadline
and it's a recognition not an audit so
they won't be inspected
um
i just want to say part of it
what's good for older people is good for
everyone so even though
we're looking at older people it will
benefit the rest of the community having
people think outside the box and develop
products and making things more
accessible for those in prams or any
other disability as well as
everything else
thanks
uh thanks carly for that um any
discussion or queries from the floor
questions from the floor
it's really
interesting the comment that you made
regarding covert because
i dare say that a lot of
older people or
elder citizens
with various poles cones
dots on floor
stripes stand here don't do this don't
do that
um it is a difficult time for them um
and you actually i know even
from myself you're not quite sure where
you meant to be some days whether you're
talking through a piece of glass or
and probably it's what
our elder
members of the community confront have
confronted every day for for a long time
the shops they probably wouldn't go into
because it was just such a
navigation navigational issue to to get
from
not knocking something off the cow uh
the the shelf or
causing a scene or causing a problem so
um i think it is one of those things
that you tend to forget uh when you're
younger but as you get older you start
to understand the
issues that strike us so
if there's no discussion
about councillor
not a discussion just a comment that um
i think it's a great plan it's good that
businesses are already
signed up kylie and and
taking advantage of that i mean little
things do help you know just even a
clear path to the counter sometimes
but often too as we age that equals
invisibility
so
i think it's good that we're
working to work with those people in the
community that
will actually benefit from this
i'll move the report
i'm happy to second that and i was
encouraged by uh kylie talking about
opportunities to change your hairstyle
so i'll keep that one in mind when
when the time comes worship um don't
change it too much
a few adaptations
thank you councillors
and uh
moves on thank you kylie for that
you've had a few items there so you can
breathe easily now if you've through the
dragon's dead
uh our last uh item here is obviously uh
from our community strategy manager in
regard to a progress report on how we're
doing and where we're going and what
we're doing so
i'll hand it over to there
okay i'm not going to go through
everything in the report because some of
the things you've already heard about
today but i guess um it was suggested to
me that i should just give you an update
a year on into the
job because it came in november and it's
but past years 14 months
but um the first part i would say was
focused quite strongly on past projects
and things that
either needed a bit of a revision
or
a refresh
there was quite a strong focus on the
establishment of relationships with
community organizations and government
agencies
and of course the establishment of the
community strategy team which includes
myself the community empowerment
coordinator mark
and pastoral care coordinator nancy and
that's a contract throughout the june
this year
and just ready for living coordinator
which you've heard from kylie today
merrill task force for jobs definitely
took quite a lot of my time and working
out
how do we actually do this
and i'm pleased with the results that
we've had and i've just actually spent
the last five days working on a photo
shoot two of those days were scoping and
three were actually shooting with a
professional photographer some of that
work was all around employment and
work that will prove beneficial
in trying to attract people
but one of the things that was really
nice feedback for me to hear was both
from the young person of how much the
program had actually benefited them and
at the end of some of the shoots some of
the young people came and approached me
and actually said thank you to the
council
so you know people really
have appreciated it and so have the
businesses and i guess it was very
inspiring to see
the quality of young people in these
jobs and them loving what they're doing
you can clearly see they're really
enjoying their work
so that was
really nice for me to see that
first you know hand today and yesterday
and we're sitting at i think around 39
placements and we have about another six
or seven contracts
uh in negotiation at the moment
so
we have the
50 is the target by the end of june
which i think we're easily going to
surpass
so we probably won't have enough funding
to support all the businesses that would
like support it with the young people so
that's on top of the 50 from last year
as well yes yes that's right
and you've heard about youth sector
today you've heard about welcome plans
today
when i first came here i did quite a bit
of work in the event space and working
out strategy for council was a couple of
main objectives around that was making
sure that we understand the reputation
gore has as far as an events
in arts
or town and district and the fact that
we are the events capital for southland
and have some really success significant
events
um
and that you know to to maintain and
grow that it has to be resourced
appropriately and of course it's been a
really tough year for the team and
events because of covert but a lot of
amazing work has gone on in the planning
and that won't be lost we've heard from
great south today just transitions i've
started working with bobby on the
process and making sure that google
district is
well included
in the report that goes to government i
think by the end of april
international students have been
approached by google high school in
saint peter's to for in a discussion
about the international students that
come to go district and you know when
coverts behind us they will want to
attract more international students and
how can
our organisation
assist with that
just make a comment on the trout project
i have the first draft on my desk and
yet to start reading it as a significant
document
and
right through the process of getting to
that draft have been working um with the
consultants
on that they've done a huge amount of
research both in google districts around
new zealand and overseas for this
project so
the intention for me is now to go
through the draft get any changes that
we think we need and then it will be
back to the working group for the impot
to see what what the next steps are
and we had the workshop
on district identity and how to build an
identity and the challenges between our
three positioning statements
the brown trout capital of the world the
new zealand country music capital and
rural city living
so there's more work that needs to be
done on those
and then attached to this report is the
community strategy work plan so this has
come out of ready for growth so you'll
remember we had the workshop that we
reviewed
ready for growth and
elective members commented on what was
no longer relevant in the plan and what
should go forward into a work program
under the community strategy team so
that documents attached and i don't
think that there will be
anything on there that would jump out
and you would be surprised by but i'm
happy to answer any questions you might
have
thanks ben for that
obviously we've had quite a few of the
projects sort of discussed today but uh
i'll open up a discussion or comment
from uh council dixon
oh thank you mr chair just to comment in
it's great to see the progress report
and
i think um
it's great to see the projects that
you're involved in and
pushing great south to recognise gore
that's important
thanks
yeah look i'm the same mr uh mr chair
but you know the progress has been
significant and uh the value that that
ann has brought
to this part of our operation uh is is
significant so thank you
cancer reed thank you
yes definitely and your input is across
all of those things and and obviously
the fact that you've driven and you can
see that big picture where sometimes
other people may be too close and just
that oversight that you provide is
extremely good i would ask
but where do you think the future lies
do you see any other projects or or
holes that need to have something
organized to fix
to things
you are a fixer
i think the biggest challenge for you in
this space is resource because the
resource is people and without money
attached to projects it's really hard to
make progress
so
we're possible we're accessing funding
and you know like
that will limit the our ability to
deliver and so that's why the
partnerships with people is really
really critical
to see what we can achieve in
partnership
yeah
and i
we did discuss i think in the workshop
around community planning
and the need for community plans for our
smaller areas within the district i
think the most important thing around
that we we don't have that on this work
plan at the moment is
that
community planning needs to come from
the community in the first instance and
should we get any approaches we're open
to facilitating those those types of
projects or sector plans
but i think for now what you see here is
what we know about and
people of the community that have asked
for support yeah
yeah and i think from my perspective
what's really important is to not have
that much that you can't achieve
anything
yeah
you've achieved a great deal in a very
small space of time
and i don't know steve may want to
comment on that as well i'm not sure
yes thanks so much i just want to
endorse the comments of councils
what we wanted to
do here is to really put out
to the council the the pathways that and
a team have forged in the last 18 months
and to give some clarity about
what we're doing because it's fair to
say when anne came to the role
there was a lot of historical effort but
perhaps it lacked a bit of focus and
there were a lot of people that had
input into someone's earlier plans but
this is now
taking a lot more refined
view of things
and has actually done
and has done a bit of
cleansing as it were in terms of quietly
retiring some things and accent
accenting others
and there's i think a lot more
comfort certainly i get in talking with
anne about where the priorities lie
and where the opportunities are
and but also dana said that
the the more successful you become
the more need you there is for
questioning whether you've you're
adequately resourced to actually advance
these initiatives in the time of
um time frame and pace that you desire
so
there's no doubt a discussion that we'll
have at estimates time but um i've
certainly endorsed the comments of
elected members that and the team really
started to create a lot of impact in the
community and i think that's a key thing
i'd say is that the networks that um
they have created in the community are
quite different really than what we had
18 months ago
and it really touches social economic
and cultural so it's fantastic
just another question
do we need to blow our own trumpet a
little more to the ratepayers to know
let them know exactly what these
initiatives have led to
just a thought
yeah it's
it's obviously one of the things that
you've got a
small team that's putting out a
big big input
um
and probably from the fact that if you
cut a tree down or you put a new bit of
concrete down on the ground everyone
drives past it and sees it every day and
comments on it where a lot of this work
is fluid it moves within the community
it creates value it creates systems and
networks that happens and they form
and they develop and they grow
and a lot of that isn't seen
and there's certain probably parts of
the community that won't notice it or
won't see it but they'll benefit from it
so i'm not sure how we showcase it
or how you actually
put it forward i think this plan here
uh well the work plan clearly outlines
where we're going and the volume of work
and the volume of projects that we're
involved in so
i know it goes on to our hub and through
our comms but i'm not sure
whether we communicate it more i know we
um
media wise we try and utilise as much as
as we can and
anything you'd like to add to that about
how you showcase it more or
blow our own trumpet as you say
probably our team's not a team that
isn't deploying with trump but we just
like getting their work done um i think
when we look at some of the initiatives
you know if you look at closing the gaps
we've definitely had a really strong
comms plan around it and key messages
that are targeting both youth and
targeting
the business
and so i think people are very aware of
that piece of work i think and we're
doing the same with
the work we're doing in ready for living
we've definitely got a strong calm
strategy around those pieces of work
some of the other work is probably still
a work in progress yeah
but
we can certainly take those comments on
board and maybe with sonia's help work
out things that we could profile more
so
sorry
thank you
through you mr chair
um and i think it would be
great to get some of the youth council
ideas on opportunities and in ways
forward and one of the things i'm
thinking about that they have been
involved in is waste
i think it would be
ideal to get
to get them involved
they probably already are we can
certainly um
further advance those things they
certainly have been involved in some
projects but i know mark's definitely
got plans to
lift the leadership coming through from
the youth council this year
so just uh uh taking up on a question
that uh councillor reed asked mr chair
and you know what does the future hold
and it is a really good question but i
think the
investment in in time and energy and
money
into what we're creating here is going
to serve us very well as as the future
of local government changes
and and that's something we haven't
really considered too much as a council
but it's probably something the
community strategy committee should be
turning its mind to was
you know the the
the panel that are considering the
options to put to government about what
the future of the local government
holds i think leads very much down the
track of what we're doing now
um but you know that's something that
perhaps the
community strategy committee could turn
its mind to just to
in a way that we can educate councillors
about what the future looks like and
educate the community as to what the
future looks like you know we've got two
significant parts of our
of our operation both um water delivery
and uh and planning
uh and
resource consenting are likely to be
um delivered outside of a council
operation
so what does that mean for us as a
council
and and there's there's a lot of
politics in this absolutely
but when the politics are done
and the dust settled then it's going to
have to be the disorganization
um
that delivers whatever the requests are
okay then
good commentary there uh
in regard to that and please receive
we've got a good good team a really good
team here putting out uh some big input
bing output and uh yeah
much appreciated from the uh obviously
the council and the community um could i
have someone to
oh sorry sorry oh sorry max
thank you mr chief i can just make a
quick comment coming back to um
carrying out projects
we'll have to adapt
online obviously
please watch this
when it comes to closing the gaps every
single
referral that we've had over the last
month
so that's
uh thanks for that mark sorry
i'm
looking right looking left and looking
behind
i think i'm in the driver's test
if we just have someone to
to move that that is
a work plan and progress report to be
received
uh councillor reid and secretary
councillor dixon and
once again thank you for the
thank you for the quality and the
standard of work that you guys are
putting through
um it's to a very very high standard
um with that uh
that's the end of our agenda so i'll
call them unless there's any more i
didn't actually ask was any late
business or
no um i'll call the meeting to a close
uh thank you for attendance councils